[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe la
transition énergétique est au coeur de
l'actualité en france avec évidemment le
mouvement v gilet jaune mais c'est aussi
un sujet de préoccupation pour l'union
européenne engagée dans une politique
environnementale importante le soutien
grâce à ces fonds européens est des
projets en faveur de l'environnement
c'est le cas notamment dans les yvelines
à montigny le bretonneux auprès de 150
logements sont en pleine rénovation
thermique pour une meilleure efficacité
énergétique
reportage à suivre dès le début de cette
émission dans la deuxième partie du 7-8
europe a enregistré au parlement
européen de bruxelles nous rencontrerons
pervenche berès eurodéputés socialistes
spécialisé sur les questions économiques
nous évoquerons la réforme de la zone
euro souhaitée par emmanuel macron à
peine soutenu par l'allemagne et en gala
merkel un sujet économique et budgétaire
qui prend un reflet particulier avec les
tensions autour du budget italien puis
vous retrouverez nos rendez vous
habituel sur une date et qui a marqué
l'histoire de l'europe et la comparaison
européenne consacré ce mois ci aux
organismes génétiquement modifiés
[Musique]
trois ans après la coop 21 à quelques
jours maintenant de la coop 24 qui doit
débuter en pologne lundi 3 décembre les
problématiques environnementales refont
surface en france
évidemment avec les gilet jaune mais
aussi en europe où les partis
écologistes connaissent une poussée
électorale récente dans certains pays
l'union européenne est engagée en faveur
de l'environnement et de la lutte contre
le changement climatique avec notamment
un objectif celui d'augmenter de 27 %
d'ici à 2030 l'efficacité énergétique du
vieux continent pour y parvenir l'europe
finance différents projets c'est le cas
à montigny-le-bretonneux dans les
yvelines où 144 logements profitent de
ces fonds européens pour des travaux de
rénovation thermique
reportage pour le moment les travaux ne
sont visibles qu'à l'extérieur du
bâtiment
c'est pourtant l'ensemble de cette
résidence qui va bénéficier d'une
importante rénovation thermique 144
logements en tout construit au milieu
des années 80 et devenus de véritables
passoires quand les températures
baissent à la proche de l'hiver on avait
beaucoup de d'un confort qui était
remonté par les locataires des ponts
thermiques très important ça c'est dû à
l'année de construction et à la
technique de construction utilisés isolé
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de
traiter tous les ponts thermiques de
baisser la facture énergétique des
locataires mais aussi d'améliorer
grandement le confort ils ont reçu cette
sensation que le mur est froid l'hiver
ils auront une sensation de chaleur dans
le logement et donc de confort amélioré
pour rendre ces vieux bâtiments plus
efficace d'un point de vue énergétique
un nouvel isolant est en cours
d'installation sur les façades des
travaux sont également prévus sur les
terrasses dans un deuxième temps c'est
l'intérieur des logements qui seront
revus pour limiter un maximum la
consommation d'énergie les travaux
doivent permettre de dégager une
économie mensuelle de 30 à 40 euros par
mois et par foyer dans les logements
on va remplacer les portes palières on
change les convecteurs on met des
radiateurs à chaleur douce qui vont
avoir des programmateurs pour permettre
de faire des économies sur le long terme
et ont bien changé les ballons d'eau
chaude
l'opération estimée à quatre millions
cinq cent mille euros est financé à
hauteur de 550 mille euros par les fonds
européens
la fin des travaux est prévue pour le
second semestre 2010 9
les locataires de la résidence descartes
de montigny le bretonneux devrait alors
passer un hiver au chaud et économe nous
allons continuer d'évoquer ses projets
en ile-de-france qui sont aidées à
financièrement par les fonds européens
avec un invité sur notre plateau à
présent cinq mille joola bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes directeur de vira tec europe
une entreprise basée aujourd'hui dans
l'essonne anciennement basée à trappes
dans les yvelines que vous avez créé en
2010 et spécialisés alors c'est un peu
compliqué on va essayer de de
familiariser tout ça dans la médecine de
précision et le diagnostic personnalisé
en transplantation
justement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi consiste votre
activité depuis depuis huit ans
maintenant alors notre activité se
focalise à utiliser le système
immunitaire toute maladie est la
conséquence d'une dune d'un tissus
endommagés ou de ceux croissance
anormale de cellules qui vont générer et
exprimer des antigènes ces antigènes
vont être détectées par le système
immunitaire et donc nous nous utilisons
ce système immunitaire pour détecter
cette anomalie
on peut l'appliquer dans du diagnostic
précoce de pathologies dans du
monitoring et notamment ont dans la
transplantation puisque on focalise sur
une des trois molécules qui est le
système à sheila donc le système à
tshela permet justement de savoir si un
donneur et un receveur sont compatibles
lors d'une greffe ici sur ce type de
projet là précisément que vous avez a
bénéficié de fonds européens en hauteur
je crois de près de 300 mille roses et
d'ailleurs de des informations à
nous montrer là dessus alors
effectivement on
à candidater pour un projet fédère qui
un financement européen sur lequel on a
accès nos recherches sur le système à
chela dans le cadre de la greffe et on
règle ça veut dire quoi vous faites des
vous mettez en place une méthode pour
pour que le récepteur est le donneur
soit le plus compatible possible alors
effectivement on il existe déjà
aujourd'hui des technologies qui
permettent de savoir si un donneur et un
receveur sont compatibles mais nous on a
rajouté un paramètre qui est
l'expression parce que on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui ce canton donneur et un
receveur sont compatibles h et là ils
sont identiques
on ne sait pas s'ils expriment de la
même manière ces molécules là or la
transplantation même en compatibilité
entière n'est pas tout le temps un
succès il ya des échecs
il ya des receveurs qui vont exprimer
des anticorps contre le greffon qui vont
essayer de le rejeter c'est le rejet et
et nous justement on parie sur le fait
que ces événements arrivent parce que
les deux molécules entre le donneur
fallait molécule du donneur et du
receveur même s'ils sont identiques ne
s'exprime pas au même niveau si on vend
ou jamais de votre projet à vous pourrez
par exemple le risque de venir 0 grâce à
votre projet ou alors c'est impossible
ça alors il n'y a pas de risque zéro
il ya toujours un risque simplement
aujourd'hui les complications post grève
sont des maladies auto immunes
en plus du rejet 1 et d'autres
pathologies est ce qu'on peut réduire
justement sélectionnant voilà en suivant
en connaissant cette différence
d'expression et ajuster un traitement
adapté aux gaffes et commence à se
matérialiser concrètement c c c est un
fichier c'est 1 1
alors comment ça ce métal matérialise on
a des tests de biologie moléculaire
notamment de séquençage à partir à lord
arn cette fois ci parce qu'aujourd'hui
les gens travaillent cela retire de
excusez-moi de la rn l'acide
ribonucléique d'accord
qui est en fait la transcription de
l'adn et qui va être la matrice pour
donner lieu à la protéine qui exprime
etc et la molécule la différence entre
l'adn l'adn on les rites on a toujours
cette une matrice figer la rn lé canton
exprime et donc nous ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on travaille sur cet arn pour
identifier les la compatibilité à chela
mais aussi identifier le nombre
d'expressions de chaque mode de chacals
elle en termes de gains qu'est ce que ça
apporte
on va dire un financement européen un
peu de notoriété de légitimité aussi
peut-être alors ce que ça apporte
surtout c'est que ça ça fait une
collaboration lacets collaboration
tripartite entre où ira tech l'ap-hp
mais aussi de notre société qui
s'appelle primadiag qui fait qu'ils
fabriquent des automates
donc ce qui veut dire que derrière tout
ça lorsqu'on aura fait la preuve la
preuve du concept et qu'on aura un kit
j'irai validé on pourra l'intégrer dans
une solution automatisée avec
collaboration de primadiag et on pourra
la valider sur des patients avec l'ap-hp
et donc commercialisé environ aura un
produit en fin de course qui sera
commercialisable en france et à
l'étranger
merci ça me joue la dette revenu sur
notre plateau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
et puis aussi bonne chance pour vos
recherches très important pour le futur
de la médecine merci beaucoup merci
sachez d'ailleurs que si vous souhaitez
savoir quels projets sont financés par
des fonds européens dans votre région
votre département
l'europe vient de lancer un site
internet dédié spécialisé là-dedans
l'adresse affiche sur vos écrans vous y
retrouverez des exemples et lien pour en
savoir plus sur ces fonds européens
justement avant de poursuivre cette
émission au parlement européen de
bruxelles pour l'interview politique une
information encore sur l'europe en ile
de france avec une soirée contre les
fausses nouvelles qui était organisé il
ya quelques jours à montigny le
bretonneux initiée par les décodeurs de
l'europe
le mouvement européen des yvelines et le
centre europe direct de saint germain en
laye une soirée pour répondre aux
interrogations des citoyens et tordre le
cou aussi à quelques idées reçues
écoutez à ce propos le représentant
adjoint de la commission européenne en
france beaucoup de citoyens pensent que
l'europe a tous les pouvoirs à des
compétences extrêmement étendue alors
que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
ce sont en fait les états membres qui
ont décidé de manière souveraine de
déléguer un certain nombre de
compétences à l'union européenne l'union
européenne n'est pas nécessairement ce
que les gens peuvent percevoir comme
étant une union par exemple qui sert
seulement les grandes banques
l'industrie etc
l'europe sociale est une réalité et les
forces nouvelles où les interrogations
sont nombreuses autour de l'euro la
monnaie unique s est l'objet en partie
de la deuxième partie de cette émission
avec l'eurodéputée pervenche berès un
entretien enregistré au parlement
européen de bruxelles
[Musique]
ta revanche berès bonsoir bonsoir on a
l'habitude de vous recevoir souvent dans
cette émission vous êtes il faut
reconnaître une spécialiste des sujets
européens très accessible aussi
disponibles il faut le dire pour les
pour les médias si lors de notre
dernière interview en février nous
avions largement évoqué ensemble les
réformes envisagées pour la zone euro
est porté par le président français
budget spécial transformation du
mécanisme européen de stabilité ministre
superministre on pourrait dire des
finances de la zone euro
huit mois plus tard mise à part vous et
moi encore une fois plus personne ne
semblant en parler comment vous
expliquer ce constat assez alarmant
finalement et pourquoi ça n'avance pas
depuis depuis des mois selon vous ce qui
est vrai c'est que l'actualité a invité
d'autres sujets sains dans les gros
titres européens la question de la
menace extérieure d'une certaine manière
avec les comportements du président des
états unis donald trump
l'évolution la tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine
le comportement de poutine en russie bon
tout ça c'était déjà le cas à son sujet
de tension la est là et elle et elle est
importante parce qu'elle oblige l'union
européenne à se repositionner par
rapport à l'extérieur et pas uniquement
à ces défis intérieurs et puis
évidemment la question des migrants vous
allez bien ya huit mois s'était déjà là
j'avais lu dans mes pensées
ce sujet là on poids zone quand même
beaucoup l'action des leaders et on voit
bien que sommet après sommet dans
l'ordre de leurs priorités doivent
d'abord s'occuper de la question des
migrants
ensuite la question du mexique et
finalement ce sujet dont vous et moi
savons qu'il est absolument essentiel
est qu'il est comme lui un arc boutant
pour l'union européenne qui est
l'approfondissement du no économiques et
monétaires le fait de doter la zone euro
d'un budget est important mais n'est pas
aujourd'hui la priorité absolue de
une salle de la mairie absolue parce que
sinon l'euro ne va pas sur vie 1
mais ça suffit pas à imposer dans
l'agenda européen comme priorités la
réforme de la zone euro écoutez d'ici la
fin du mandat
il nous reste une petite fenêtre
d'opportunité qu'on va essayer de saisir
qui est une proposition de la commission
européenne a mis sur la table où pour la
première fois elle propose un outil
budgétaire spécifique pour les pays
membres de la zone euro
alors c'est un budget c'est ça de la
zone euro c'est ça dont on parle
clairement absolument c'est un c'est une
petite enveloppe 1 3 milliard donc c'est
moins de 5% de du pipe de la zone donc
on va parler de l'embryon d'un budget de
la zone euro mais cette proposition est
là il se trouve que je suis rapporteur
sur cette proposition
comme souvent avec un co rapporteur de
la cd ou rhymer bug avec lequel vous
souvenez j'ai déjà fait tout
l'approchent d'initiatives pour dire que
nous avions besoin de ce budget de la
fnaut donc la droite vous êtes ensemble
sur ce sujet en tout cas au parlement
européen en tout cas il ya toujours
cette idée que si au parlement européen
à j'arrive à mettre d'accord avec
quelqu'un de la cd ou s'adonnent comme
les indications qui a un accord possible
au conseil
et si on veut déboucher d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est utile quel est notre idée
sur ce qu'on devrait pouvoir faire avec
ce budget c'est l'idée que quand vous
êtes dans la zone euro évidemment vous
ne pouvez pas d'évaluer votre monnaie on
parle de 19 pays d'ailleurs un peut-être
préciser que yann 28 pays aujourd'hui
dans l'union européenne 7 demain mais il
ya dix-neuf pays qui ont la monnaie
unique en tant que monnaie officielle
donc c'est un bloc assez assez grande
dans l'union européenne mais le budget
de l'union européenne n'est pas du tout
adaptée aux défis que ces pays pauvres
auxquels ces pays doivent faire face le
fait que quand ils sont heurtés par une
crise et une difficulté un chômage
excessifs etc
ils ne peuvent pas dévaluer leur monnaie
pourront gagner des points de
compétitivité et du coup il faut
compenser le fait qu'ils partagent la
monnaie et la composition de la
commission propose très concrètement de
regarder comment est ce qu'un pays voit
son taux de chômage évolue je savais
bien que si un pays est touché par une
crise le premier indicateur séparation
alors va regarder ça
et de manière automatique les joies ce
bouquet pourra intervenir alors là c'est
uniquement ce budget c'est pour que ce
soit clair pour tout le monde car en cas
de vent car en cas de crise de choc
économique sur un pays sur l'économie
d'un pays de la zone euro exactement
mais c'est un angle très important ce
n'est pas pour eux c'est pas tout budget
de la saison pourrait révéler bien sûr
mais c'est l'angle le plus sensible et
le plus explicite et ce qui justifie le
plus que les pays de la zone rouge
s'organisent par rapport aux autres pays
question peut-être un peu naïve pour
vous en tout cas mais il ya déjà un
budget de l'union européenne ça suffit
pas complètement mais justement jacques
delors nous l'avait dit parfois rappelé
jacques delors réussite et un jacques
delors l'avait dit quand on est passé à
la monnaie unique
il aurait fallu repenser le budget de
l'union européenne parce que la question
le rôle du budget de l'union européenne
c'est quoi ces souvenirs la convergence
entre les états membres
oui et on a paré adapter ce budget de
l'union européenne à l'existence d'une
zone euro et cet angle mort est resté
ouvert depuis la création de l'euro il
est temps de le combler mais la
composition que je voudrais faire c'est
quand même de pouvoir aussi me servir de
cette proposition pour amorcer l'idée
d'un soutien au régime d'indemnité
chômage des états membres donc c'est un
début de projet qui verra qui va
sûrement se déployer et dans le futur ce
moment après les élections européennes
est ce que justement est-ce que vous
pensez que les choses vont bouger
concrètement encore une fois d'ici les
élections européennes on sait que
généralement quelques mois avant les
élections
plus personne ne fait rien je caricature
mais mais globalement ce schéma là il ya
ceux qui veulent terminer un certain
nombre de dossiers qui sont bien engagés
dans cette mandature d'ici la fin du
mandat et donc avant les élections
européennes
ça ne dit pas tout ça ne puisse pas les
sujets ça laisse quelques thèmes de
campagne j'en suis sûr mais je crois
qu'il ya des sujets qu'il faut pouvoir
installer mettre en place avant les
élections
sept petits budgets de la zone euro en
étant derrière questions sur ce sujet
budget veut dire forcément nouvelle
manne financière aa trouvé ça veut dire
quoi
un nouvel impôt comment vous allez
trouver par exemple c'est 30 milliards
s'ils sont vraiment mises en place
demain soit 6,7 milliards c'est une
garantie qui est dans le budget de
l'union européenne et qui permet d'aller
sur les marchés pour emprunter
ça c'est une partie du financement
l'autre partie du financement pour
expliquer les choses simplement savait
que les états membres les banques
centrales nationales honte dans le
capital de la banque centrale de
l'argent et fructifie donc ça s'appelle
le seigneur âge exact et l'argent que
rapporte on apprend des choses de cette
émission merci
cet argent qui est donc un espèce de
bénéfices qu pour les états membres dans
l'activité de la banque centrale est
aujourd'hui reversés dans le budget des
états membres
et l'idée la proposition de la
commission c'est de se servir d'une
partie de cet argent que les états
membres verserait dans un fonds qui
permettrait de rendre ces prêts à taux
zéro on va suivre cette affaire durant
les prochaines émissions on va enchaîner
tout de suite avec notre nouvelle
rubrique nommée ce jour-là un peu
d'histoire l'occasion d'évoquer les
dates clés de la construction européenne
et nous avons retenu ce mois ci le 3
octobre 1990 jour de la réunification de
l'allemagne une date importante pour le
pays et pour l'union européenne aussi
comme nous le rappelle philippe le guen
coordinateur adjoint pour le parlement
européen de la maison jean monnet basée
à bazoches sur guyonne dans les yvelines
date très importante parce que bon
d'abord il ya eu la chute du mur de
berlin le 9 novembre
89 donc pratique moins d'un an plus tard
les deux allemagnes sont réunifiées
alors que pendant je dirais toute la
période d'après la seconde guerre
mondiale on n'aurait jamais pensé que
cela puisse être possible donc on est
allé très vite entre la lah novembre 89
et octobre 90 et et bien c'est une page
d'histoire qui se tourne c'est la fin
officielle de la guerre froide
c'est le nouvel ordre européen et
mondial avec la la faim derrière aussi
des pays communistes
la satellites de l'urss et donc on est
encore je dirais dans cette période
on est encore dans les conséquences de
cette période de 1990 puisque ça a
permis ensuite la l'accession l'adhésion
de nouveaux pays
l'union européenne ce a provoqué aussi
des changements majeurs dans tout le
temps dans toute l'urss qui s'est
disloquée également par la suite donc on
voit bien que c'est pas une date toute
anodine et la réunification allemande
c'est quelque chose quand même qui
marquera l'histoire pour longtemps
pervenche berès vous êtes eurodéputé
depuis 1994 ici vous avez vu forcément
ce processus de la réunification de
l'allemagne se mettre en place
l'allemagne aussi conquérir cette
première place de puissance en europe
certains reprochent souvent d'ailleurs
aux allemands de vouloir coloré l'europe
à leur façon de jouer un rôle
hégémonique sur le vieux continent
est ce que cette critique à a du sens
selon vous vous avec votre expérience ou
c'est un mythe que certains agitent pour
mettre tous les mots du vieux continent
sur sur le dos de l'allemagne il ya une
réalité des faits qui est que
l'allemagne est géographiquement et en
terme de population le premier pays de
l'union européenne ça pourrait
d'ailleurs s'inverser je crois si j'ai
bien vu les coûts de la démographie ya
un moment avec la france est inversée
absolument si les tendances actuelles se
confirment de part et d'autre du rhin
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la france est
le deuxième pays derrière l'année mais
le fait d'être un grand pays
cela doit conduire à un certain nombre
de devoirs et des responsabilités la
question est de savoir comment est ce
que l'allemagne assume ses
responsabilités et commence justement ce
débat qui est ouvert est qu' un débat
très important vous savez que
l'allemagne est aujourd'hui le pays qui
a le plus de surplus et qui donc
bénéficier d'une certaine manière du
marché intérieur pour asseoir la
compétitivité de son économie
or d'une certaine manière
si l'une l'allemagne bénéficie de ce
marché intérieur et de cette
compétitivité
il faut il changer redistribuées ça
bouge un peu sur ce saut céline là
puisqu'on entend ce sujet des sujets
difficiles et je sais que par exemple
sur la taxation du numérique la grâce et
ça les gaffes à l'allemagne s'inquiète
des répercussions que les états unis
pourraient mettre en place contre
l'industrie automobile allemande
donc c'est un sujet de tension et sur
lequel il faut en permanence
aiguillonné la volonté des uns et des
autres parlons à présent de cette année
2010 neuf années cruciales on a
l'impression au site de se répéter
quand on parle des années cruciales avec
l'union européenne il y aura le bric
site en mars les élections européennes
au mois de mai ce semble se dessiner
aujourd'hui un duel entre on va dire
progressiste en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
nous dit dans les médias les hommes
politiques aussi entre progressistes qui
irait du centre gauche centre-droit et
nationaliste est ce que vous partagez là
ce point de vue vous vous qui avez vécu
beaucoup d'élections européennes est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse savez parlement européen il n'y
a pas deux camps un parlement européen
il ya tout un hémicycle avec une
coloration il faut occuper toutes les
places et pour occuper toutes les places
vous ne pouvez pas réduire le débat aux
pros et et aux antilles si vous faites
ça peut-être que c'est ce qui va sortir
des urnes au mois de mai prochain
peut-être que les pros et les antis vont
comprendre une place très importante
dans
au sein du parlement européen je ne le
souhaite pas parce que ça veut dire que
c'est les antilles qui aurait gagné si
le missile mois se réduit à ça c'est que
c'est les antilles qui ont gagné et moi
ce que je veux c'est que ceux qui sont
ceux qui pensent que l'union fait la
force mais qu'on a besoin de cette union
dans la diversité des expressions occupe
le plus grand spectre possible dans
l'hémicycle quand il faut que chacun
défende sous ses couleurs sa vision de
l'union européenne est ensuite on verra
avec qui on peut travailler dans le
prochain parlement
sa vision est aussi son bilan quel bilan
vous tiré de ce mandat vous à titre
personnel il ya des réformes importantes
qui ont convenu le jour récemment
peut-être le droit d'auteur enfin là oui
il ya eu des batailles magnifique de
gagner il ya eu des déplacements de
l'opinion publique pour comprendre
certains sujets par exemple la
sensibilité des citoyens sur la question
du glyphosate des ogm sont quelque chose
ou parlement européen a joué un rôle
tout à fait essentiel même si on n'a pas
remporté toutes les batailles comme nous
aurions voulu sur droits d'auteur
franchement je crois que c'est une
bataille absolument exemple protège
beaucoup plus on va le dire les
créateurs de les journalistes les
créateurs de vidéos faso aux géants du
numérique qui choisirent de force
voilà savez si google vous donne le
monde vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
pouvoir de négociation si la loi dit que
google doit payer pour exploiter votre
travail ça change la donne
et comme socialiste je suis très fier de
cette loi parce que je considère qu'elle
consiste à dans le monde moderne du
numérique rémunérer le travail des
auteurs des journalistes c'est pas une
mince affaire face à des thématiques de
la question comme par exemple à la crise
migratoire est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est possible d'imposer ces sujets là
aussi encore le numérique
l'environnement eau pour les débats des
élections européennes en 2019 vous ça va
encore se cristalliser sur sur la
thématique notamment migratoires c'est
ce qui se dessine là aussi aujourd'hui
non je crois pas je crois que
on est dans une évolution de la
mobilisation des citoyens qui se fait de
manière très thématique justement et
donc il ya des fenêtres d'opportunités
mais aussi sur des deux grands sera
certain mais par certains contre une
certaine solidarité mais d'abord la
contre-offensive existe vous voyez en
france par tous les mouvements de
solidarité se disent ils et puis les
thématiques par exemple de la santé de
la qualité de l'alimentation de la
culture de la défense du droit d'auteur
auront leur place doivent l'avoir en
tout cas merci
pervenche berès d'avoir répondu à toutes
nos questions voici notre rubrique et
chez nos voisins ça se passe comment la
culture et la commercialisation des ogm
ce mois-ci organismes génétiquement
modifiés varient d'un état à l'autre
chacun peut décider ou non d'interdire
les ogm sur son territoire
on fait le point avec olivier jane white
responsable du centre europe direct à
saint germain en laye alors actuellement
il ya soixante deux ogm qui sont
autorisés en europe sur van citer
quelques-uns alors on a par exemple
récemment on a le coton 281 24 236 on a
aussi par exemple le maïs bt11 où on a
encore le soja bps cv 127,9 actuellement
il n'y a qu'un seul ogm qui est autorisé
dans l'agriculture dans l'agriculture
européenne et c'est le monsanto 810 et
il est principalement il est uniquement
cultivé au nez en espagne et au portugal
alors si peu d'eau gm sont cultivés au
sein de l'union européenne on constate
cependant que les états en apportent
davantage
alors après il faut faire une différence
entre les ogm qui vont être vendus aux
consommateurs finals et ceux qui sont
vendus
aux producteurs si ce sont des ogm qui
seront vendus aux consommateurs finals
ces ogm sont obligés de respecter les
différentes normes d'affichage qui fait
que notamment un produit doit être
identifié en tant que le contenant des
ogm
s'il contient 1 0 plus de 0,9 pour cent
de gm dans sa composition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]